thank you for being with us here this
evening my objective here with my talk
is to awaken the hearts to help to
stimulate and motivate everyone in this
room to stop ponder and reflect on these
key and important points that I'm going
to mention on what's it all about what's
the purpose of my life and why am I here
and where am I going when I depart from
this beautiful place it doesn't make
sense that everything in this room that
we can see that we can observe has a
purpose but the human being doesn't have
a purpose I challenge everybody in this
room to find me one thing that doesn't
have a purpose inside the room and
outside the room if we ended up on the
moon we want to know why we were here
maybe they might be a Starbucks I go get
a Frappuccino a cappuccino take a little
break get myself together but then I'd
be on the hunt to figure out why am I on
the moon let alone why am I on this
earth if you ask somebody at the bus
stop where are you going and they said I
don't know you think that's a problem if
somebody at the University is asked what
are you doing here and a people person
didn't have a clue that be a problem so
my objective here is to awaken the
hearts and the minds to contemplate and
to think on these very important points
why am I here what is my purpose now I
got to ask this question to a elderly
individual in his 70s and I asked him
young man being facetious
I want to benefit from your years of
experience and your wisdom would you
allow me to ask you a question and he
said sure young man go ahead I said have
you ever in all of your years of living
have you ever thought about or has
anyone ever asked you this important
question what's the purpose of life and
why are you here I said the car that
we're driving has a purpose the keys in
the ignition have a purpose the head on
your head has a purpose what about us do
we have a purpose he said young man
that's a very profound question you've
left me something to think about I
haven't really given it much thought but
now I definitely will my job was done
and that is my objective here with you
guys today
to leave you with something deep and
profound to think about some people
might say well I figured this one out
Eddie it's to make a lot of money go
ahead and add Fame to the equation in
power but we know they've been people
who have amassed enough money that in a
hundred lifetimes they wouldn't be able
to spend it and people have committed
suicide because they've lost a fraction
of it and it didn't bring that peace and
contentment that when one does figure
out the purpose of why they are here it
should bring some solace to the heart
someone might say well you know I get a
lot of comfort and solace in helping
people that's the purpose I figured it
out but it has to be universal it has to
fit for all because there are some
people who can't even help themselves
let alone help other people like a
person in the wheelchair
someone who's blind someone who's
handicapped someone might say you know
what it's to start a family is to have a
lot of kids now someone might object say
you know I've been there done that and
she took half of it and I don't have any
more to give or someone has tried to
remarry and they just can't so it has to
be something that's universal and it has
to be a fit all for all so my objective
here is to awaken the heart and that
voice deep down inside and to start to
ask because design indicates a designer
and we would go back to the manufacturer
of the car to ask how to operate all
these fancy little gadgets on the iPhone
and the iPad and iMac so if I can do my
small little part and give that advice
for each and every one of us to stop
ponder reflecting to think and to awaken
the heart and that little voice inside
and to ask the designer who designed all
this what's my purpose what's it all
about why am I here thank you very much
you